alright guys welcome back this is the I
don't know 19th video I think financial
charting within Python and matplotlib
what we did last time is actually define
our RSI function not positive it's going
to work just yet but I think it will and
so now what we want to do is actually
you know take this returned relative
strength index and plot it
so we've already made the space port and
actually let's just run this real quick
and make sure it runs okay so at least
we don't have a syntax issue and you
know we've got the space for art aside
but we don't actually have anything
there so let's scroll down here this is
our area for RSI now so scroll down to
your you know axes zero right underneath
your definition of access zero that's
what we'll begin first off we'll say RSI
equals RSI function and you do this on
closed prices or adjusted to closed
I don't you've got the next a X 0 dot
plot and we want to go ahead and plot
date RSI and let's just do that real
quick and then we'll just throw a random
color to it and make sure everything
worked all right there is our RSI
plotted on here we will change the color
in a second or maybe we'll just leave it
here and eventually get to changing and
I don't I haven't decided
anyway you can look at the digits and
see okay it looks like everything is
between 0 and 100 so that's that's a
good start so the next thing we might
want to do maybe just have two grid
lines one for seventy one for 30 and
then get rid of like all these things
over here but anyway it looks like our
function for RSI did indeed work so
that's good party another thing we might
want to do is a X 0 dot set underscore
while and
and make this zero to 100 now the reason
obviously you want to do that is because
that is the range so you always kind of
want to look at it with that in mind so
there we go
now let's see what else do we want to do
close out of this and program so let's
see now we're at this point here and the
next thing I think that we should
probably do is maybe fix the color of
the RS I'd line and then also let's fix
this legend so we'll do that real quick
and then we'll continue compounding on
the RSI drawing implied the next video
so the first thing I want to do is
scroll down to a x1 where we've got this
legend going on here and I think instead
what we'll do is we'll say ma legend for
ma leg for ma legend equals that then
what we wanted to do is say ma leg dot
get underscore frame empty parameters
that's nothing
dot set underscore alpha and for this
we'll do is your point four and let's do
that let's run that real quick cool okay
so now you see the you know we've kind
of like made it a little more
transparent just in case it does cover
over data and the next thing we need to
do is we can't really read what those
numbers are so let's change that
so I guess run underneath here do pylab
dot set P in text Oh actually shoot
let's do the text IDI equals PI lab GC a
empty parameters dot get legend and then
in here you do dot get
text so that pulls out the text for us
and then down here you can use pylab set
P tags and and in here you basically say
like an array of text that you want so
right now we only have two things but
just to protect ourselves we'll do like
five just to be safe just in case we add
any extra moving averages and then color
look we'll just color them white right
so they're a little easier to understand
or see and then this means at the top I
don't think we ever imported pylab so
now we want to import pylab save it run
it that works out for us
cool so now you can see that you know
we've fixed this so in case it is
covering data and now you can read the
moving averages a little easier now the
only thing I would change is the actual
moving averages and you see that and
find them
can't remember yeah we did put them in
here so let's do 20 and 200 for those
moving averages now that running all
right cool so now that we've got we've
got that you know kind of working out
for us now I think what I'll do is cut
the video here and in the next video
I'll be showing you guys probably change
this color to the same color as volume
we'll get rid of all these ticks over
here just do a 70 and a 30 and then just
like draw like a line across it so to
make the RSI a lot easier to read and so
I think that's what we'll do for the
next video so stay tuned for that as
always thanks for watching thing if you
support your subscriptions and until
next time